hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it is Magnus
Carlson versus alireza firuja in round
seven of this year's Norway chess it is
uh the former world champion against the
chosen one uh Magnus wanted the face
alireza for the title but it just wasn't
meant to be and okay he resigned the the
title amongst that was only one of the
reasons uh but a clash between the two
of them regardless of the format is um
definitely something to be promoted even
though Magnus is no longer the world
classical Champion he is still the top
rated player in the world so let's check
it out it's a brilliant game you guys
will enjoy it Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with the Ponte E4
alireza replies with Pawn to C5 and this
is already uh somewhat of a surprise to
Magnus but we will discuss this um a bit
later uh Knight to F3 we have Pawn to E6
now going for this French variation of
the Sicilian and Magnus based Bishop to
D3 so a weird move to face but it uh
Magnus is hoping that it's something
that I'll is a does not have prepared we
ignite the C6 castles and alireza just
throws in Pawn to G5 and this this is
the absolute best setup recommended by
the engine alireza is not surprised by
Bishop to D3 uh too too much and there
is one game in the database where the
moon was played as Bishop to D3 is a
favorite of Grand Master David paravian
he played it against Boris grachov in
the Moscow championship in 2016 but he
lost the game so Bishop to D3 never
actually uh played with positive result
but here instead we have Bishop to B5
and it is now as of move 5 that we have
a completely new game which is absolute
Madness uh for a classical game so let's
see how all it is a continues Bishop to
G7 we have Bishop characters on C6 B
captures and now Pawn to D3 uh Pawn to
G4 by alireza and now Knight F to D2 We
have Pawn to H5 going very hard here and
the King side going after magnus's King
already Knight the B3 putting pressure
on the C5 Pawn while it is a defends it
and now Pawn to F4 and you don't really
care about G captures and F3 Alpha song
because that would only favor white and
give white more space so Knight the E7
now Shifting the Knight over to G6 and
here Magnus plays something that looks
like you shouldn't be able to play it uh
he plays Bishop to D2 he just gives up
the B2 pawn and will be offering the
full rook and we are only on move 11. uh
Bishop captures some B2 all it is a
captures it now Bishop to A5 attacking
the black queen and okay Queen to D7 and
now Knight one to D2 just going for
development offering the full rook and a
one another full Rook The Exchange on A1
and Alex just goes back to G7 the
problem with capturing The Rook is that
after Queen captures what do you play
here with black it's such a I mean look
at this the bishop slices over here the
queen slices all the way this way uh the
F5 can be played E5 can be played then
the Knight comes the the E4 or E5 Knight
comes to C4 and then the D6 I mean it's
something thing that you would see in a
morphe versus Anderson game 150 years
ago so it is a not uh not willing to
find out he just goes back Bishop to G7
and now Queen to E1 centralizing the
queen and also maybe with ideas of
Shifting the queen over to the king side
uh Bishop to A6 and now Rook to D1 again
like it was played 150 years ago a
beautiful attacking move uh you know
that um you will want to play Knight to
C4 at some point putting more pressure
on B6 and if the bishop wants to trade
for Knight then the D file will open up
and here okay you could consider a move
like E5 and it would not be a bad move
for example E5 F5 and now Knights the G8
fighting for the F6 Square let's say
Knight comes to C4 and then Knight to F6
and okay it's a nice position you can
play this with black but alireza goes
for Ponte F5 instead and now Pawn to E5
Magnus just wants to weaken the D6 spawn
and um by extent the the C5 Pawn so
Knights the G6 and now not capturing
immediately first Magnus goes Knight to
C4 and this is what we were discussing
you cannot allow Knight to D6 even D5
Knight to D6 check is just terrible for
black so alireza has to trade uh Bishop
captures on C4 the captures in C4 now
opening up the uh D file and now Pawn to
D5 we have Knight captures and C5
attacking alirez's queen queen to C8 and
not Knight back to B3 now the Knight
comes to D4 and will be pressuring C6
and E6 at the two bases of the pawn
chain we have Castles by alireza and now
Bishop to B4 and this is a beautiful
Tempo move by Magnus he wants to bring
the bishop to D6 without wasting time so
you attack The Rook alireza moves at the
E8 and now Bishop to D6 also preventing
the a the A8 Rook from coming into the
game uh we have Queen to A6 now putting
pressure on the C4 Pawn putting pressure
on the A2 Pawn but Magnus just plays
Queen to C3 and now uh alireza plays
Rook a to d8 here the movie Wanted plays
C5 it looks really odd but the point is
that after Bishop captures on C5 now you
play Queen captures on C4 and after
Queen captures D captures let's say
Knight to D4 you will just play Rook 8
to B8 and your position is uh well very
very active
you don't really care about Bishop
captures and A7 because then we're K8
and then you go after the A2 point you
go after the C2 pawn and you will have a
lot of counter play for this active
position but instead oh it is a win to
Rook a to d8 and now Magnus just throws
in a C5 and now you you do not like this
I mean look at your pieces the bishop
here is an absolute Beast a true Monster
uh you cannot go to B8 so you will never
have an active Rook the Rooks are
absolutely useless the bishop useless
the Knight useless so how can alireza
play this there aren't many moves you
can play some awaiting moves like Rook
D7 King F7 or something like that maybe
some active move like Queen to A3 you
never want to capture an E2 of course uh
so Bishop to H6 attacking the F4 Pawn
Magnus just defends it and now Rook to
D7 so now alireza can basically just
wait and see what Magnus does Knight the
D4 puts pressure on uh C6 and E6 and now
Rook to F7 and just a waiting move with
Rook to B1 by Magnus claiming the B file
for himself and now now point the H4 we
have Queen to D3 offering a queen trade
and uh alireza could do this but then
after captures captures uh you do not
have an active piece none of your pieces
can enter the game this this would just
be silly so instead we have Queen to A4
by alireza uh and now okay you have to
be a little bit careful the Knight on D4
might be hanging if the queen moves uh
Pawn to A3 just nicely defending that
pawn with the queen also now Rook the B4
will be an idea so Pawn to A5 stopping
Rook to B4 and now Rook F to D1 by
Magnus and here we have H Captain G3 H
captures and like I said alireza is
basically without a move so he finds the
only way to activate his pieces and that
is by getting rid of them he plays
Bishop captures on F4 and okay you will
have to accept this upon captures Knight
captures now attacks the queen and now
Queen to B3 yeah Queen to E3 would be
even more
uh more potent but uh or Magnus knows
that uh he is a very
um uh you know uh he's doing very well
in this end game so Queen to B3 offers a
queen crane And alireza Trades Queen
captures on B3 Rook capture some B3 and
now it is a place Pawn to A4 a bit more
precise would be Knights to H3 with
check and then after King F1 Pawn to F4
and then just March those pawns for down
the board it would still be a better
position for white but um it would be
very hard to find the move here for
white like if you go for Knight captures
on C6 which is the only move that uh
well kinda uh at least
strides the word towards Victory then
Pawn to F3 and then if you go back
Knight to D4 there's even A4 attacking
the rookie Rook before G3 even and now
you have to capture on F3 uh but it's
not uh it's not bad Knight captures on
F3 so now you're hoping for Rook
captures and King to G2 which would
attack The Rook end the Knight but first
Knight to F2 you attack the rook and D1
no okay we have to play an ig5 attacks
The Rook Knight captures on D1 with um a
discovery on the king uh Knight captures
an F7 King captures and pawn to C6 and
now whether you can survive this or not
it's very hard to say rechecking to G1
um I mean it's it's it's a tough
position but maybe you can survive
uh however Ponte A4 was played now comes
Rook to B4 and now Rook to H7 now all it
is that once control play would Rook to
H3 and uh it's uh okay if Magnus goes
for Knight captures on C6 this would
definitely go a long way because now
Knight to E2 checking G3 and Rook to H3
uh uh all there is it doesn't have all
that much to show for however Magnus
played Rook to F1 he wants to attack the
Knight first we have Knight to H3 with
Chuck King to G2 and now Knights the G5
now Magnus captures on C6 Knight
captures on C6 and down Knight to the E4
and even though this is a classical game
and we are at move 38 uh a Magnus has
seven minutes on the clock and alireza
has only one minute on the clock and you
have to reach time control which means
you have to reach move 40 to get that 10
seconds increment so alireza for the
next two moves will only have a minute
on the clock uh Rook captures on e4 uh
and this is why probably why Magnus
rushed to this road captures on e4 he
wanted to uh I make alireza work for his
meal uh and uh well he probably thought
that he would just blunder in those uh
two moves uh but Rook capture Sunny for
is uh such a forcing move that you
basically make Alvarez's life much much
easier he doesn't have to think about
his reply he's just gonna play it the
actual way to win this is Knight to E7
with check and now the point is uh you
you kind of have to capture if you don't
capture you you have nothing here I mean
you're just uh you're just worse uh
you're gonna have to play Rook captures
on E7 and now after Bishop captures an
E7 uh you have to capture again because
you're down material if you remember all
it is a sacrifice that that Bishop to
create this Pawn storm so you will have
to capture but it's not great Pawn to C6
and there's no way to stop uh Rook to B7
Rook to B7 once it lands that's it even
if you play Rook to C7 first we give a
check and then the King has to move
wherever the king moves Rogue B7 you
either win The Rook or you capture and
the promotion cannot be prevented so
Knight E7 check would definitely be a
tough move to meet you okay you could
maybe not capture the Knight you could
play a king to G7 but then Rook the B7
threatens all sorts of nasty discoveries
and uh there's absolutely nothing here
you're just uh you're you're just dead
lost you're reflecting the h8 you're
just gonna lose tonight the G6 a nice
Discovery and after King to G8 let's say
captures King captures and now Knight to
F4 uh again not much to look forward to
here you're done a full Bishop the
position completely blocked it's just
the white to push and win nothing for
black to play for here uh however Magnus
played he rushed it with Rook captures
and E4 probably was hoping that alireza
loses on time but this move 39 alireza
will not lose on time D captures an E4
and now Knights the D4 or maybe Magnus
thought actually that this was winning
but now it is a place Rook the H3 and
it's magnus's king who might get in
trouble now Magnus does get to push the
C Pawn C6 with King to F7 C7 and now
Rook eat the AJ doubling up on the H
file we have Knight the C6 now if the
Knight has a few more moves it is just a
completely winning game uh sorry uh this
could have been played but Magnus played
Knight to the C6 with with a similar
idea uh and now Rook the H2 with
checking the G3 and The Rook captures
and C2 attacks the Knight and also uh
the defends the C8 square and here
Knights the d8 with check by Magnus um
there was also this very tricky move
Rook to H1 which hopes to dislodge The
Rook from the eighth rank but of course
you're not gonna do that you're gonna
play some like Rook the C3 check and
after a few King moves let's take into
G2 okay now you could um continue
checking then we uh probably repeat the
position or if Rook the E8 then you
would try Rook to H7 with check if King
to G6 he will try Rook to E7 and now
again you cannot capture because of
promotion but now Rook the C2 checking
to G3 and King G5 uh beautiful attempt
by black and now again you cannot
capture if you capture the free rook
it's F4 Checkmate so you have to be very
careful about that but you're just gonna
move the Rook back Rook to G7 with check
once the king attacks The Rook you're
just gonna
uh move the Rook back to A7 and and so
on and so on so Rook to H1 also a fine
attempt but it uh you know doesn't do
all that much so Knight the d8 with
check was played by Magnus King to G6
and now Knight captures an E6 we have
rooked the H3 with check King to F4 and
now Rook the F3 with check magnus's King
uh really looking looking awkward there
uh Rook captures on F3 e captures on F3
and now King to G3 and here uh alireza
was very very close to winning but he
does not play it correctly here alireza
was I believe so happy that he escaped
the defeat that he just forced a draw
but F2 would go a long way uh point is
F1 will now be a queen and if you play
King G2 there's G3 you cannot capture of
course because of queening and if Knight
to F4 uh with checking G5 Knight the D3
you don't care just Pawn to F4 now King
is coming to G4 or you can even push F3
check doesn't matter so here you would
have to find a forced line let's say a
C8 Queen you have to move the Rook away
from the second rank now you're gonna
play E6 but still F3 with check comes
and after King to F1 uh even Rook the C3
Rook to C3 the only winning move but yes
we are discussing a hypothetical line uh
if Pawn to E7 You're Gonna Play root
captures on D3 and the ones uh Magnus
gets a queen it's Rook to D1 check and
that's it you are getting checkmated
only move Queen T one will capture Sunny
one will be Checkmate so these are only
some of the lines that were possible if
Pawn to F2 was played but alireza
probably happy that he escaped the jaws
of defeat goes Rook to G2 check King H4
we have Rook the H2 King G3 Rook to G2
check King H4 and it was in this
position that the players agreed to a
draw and move 52 or basically it's a
draw by threefold repetition so
absolutely incredible game uh Magnus was
completely winning then alireza was
winning and in the end uh well both
players are happy that they didn't lose
but I believe both players are also very
angry that they they didn't win this
game and now of course as you can see on
the little robot we have a c plus a now
we are also going to show an Armageddon
game which was uh just uh it was an
absolute Blitzkrieg uh here uh they
switched it up a little and of course
Magna still has wine tell it as it has
um uh black colors it has 10 minutes on
the clock Magnus has seven minutes on
the clock but Magnus has to win the game
so here Ponte E4 Magnus uh repeats it
again and now Pawn to E5 uh alireza
switches it up now he will go for his
Petrov probably one of the reasons why
Magnus played that weird Bishop to D3
line is because he prepared it for the
better of Defense Knight to F3 Knight to
F6 Knight captures on E5 we have Pawn to
D6 Knight to F3 Knight captures on e4
and now Magnus goes for it here okay uh
the top moves are D4 Knight to C3 D3 uh
Queen to E2 all possible moves but
Magnus plays Bishop to D3 and this is
only the sixth most popular continuation
so alireza has to be now very careful
but he absolutely crushed it in the
previous game will he be able to crush
it now Knight F6 we have castles uh
Bishop to E7 and now just Pawn to H3 by
Magnus we have castles and now Rook to
E1 and it seems like it's a very comps
calm position it's not some sort of a
you know crazy
um
attacking opening where you just go
straight for the black king uh and it's
Armageddon you have to win with white if
you want to win the game and here D5 and
Knight the C6 uh sorry Knight the C6 are
known moves but here Rook d8 by all it
is a new move so now as of move eight we
have a completely new game so Magnus
goes Bishop to F1 of course the bishop
cannot remain on D3 forever you have to
push those spawns uh Bishop to f8 and
the Magnus trades the Rooks Rook
captures Queen captures and pawn to D4
uh Pawn to H6 now comes Pawn to C4 with
Bishop to F5 alireza also enjoying his
rapid development Magnus really not
stopping that Knight to C3 we have
Knight to C6 and now Queen to B3 putting
pressure on the B7 Pawn alireza
defensive with Queen to C8 and now Pawn
to D5 chases away the knight uh Knight
Knight the E5 and now Knight captures on
E5 we have Pawn captures and Bishop to
E3 and already you can see that those
pawns are now marching forward this is
magnus's plan and this is basically the
idea uh behind this setup Knight to D7
fighting for the C5 square and now Rook
the C1 we have pawned the B6 uh and
Knight to a for now and now Magnus has
full control over the C5 squared the
Knight the bishop The Rook are uh joined
joined in action and C5 is coming so we
have Bishop to D6 and the Magnus strikes
on C5 Pawn to C5 B captors we have
Knight captures on C5 and now Rook to B8
and this is where the fun starts uh
Magnus says the queen is hanging and he
could choose just to move it away with a
move like Queen the C3 or queen to A3
which would both be fine but he goes for
Bishop to A6 and what an interesting use
of this bishop a bishop comes after D3
then back to the starting Square then
the A6 to attack the queen and C8 so
yeah crazy stuff here and the best way
to treat this is to play Knight captures
on C5 and attack the White Queen again
I'm just gonna show it because it wasn't
played and after Bishop captures on C5
Queen to E8 moving the queen out of
Harm's Way Magnus would do the same now
E4 and this is the counter play that you
are looking for but unless you know this
line exists you are not finding this in
a in an Armageddon game Bishop capture C
captures Queen will capture and this is
but now E3 okay you sacrifice the pawn
for activity but um you know that's
that's definitely some good activity so
instead after this uh Bishop to A6 move
alvareza played Queen to E8 and now
comes Knight to B7 and now uh alvareza
is really struggling to find moves he
plays Knight to B6 but now even Rook to
C6 Magnum just uh grabbing um uh the you
know the the the the the position
completely Knight the C8 and now Knight
captures and D6 again offering the queen
for the black queen but you can't trade
now so Knight captures on D6 and now
Queen to C3 Queen to A3 also would be
possible Magnus plays Queen the C3 puts
pressure on the C7 Pawn of course it
cannot be defended and here Bishop e for
all it as it says all right we can trade
I'm going to capture on e4 Magnus says
five and a half minutes on the clock
alireza only two and a half minutes on
the clock so Magnus captures on C7 uh
and now uh Bishop captures on D5 is the
movie we want to play objectively but
you know it's Armageddon uh when the
queen day 4 attacks the bishop on A6 and
Magnus just brings it back all the way
to F1 so Magnus just uh you know being
funny with the bishop Bishop to D3 to F1
to A6 to F1 uh I don't know uh it's just
weird but Bishop to F1 is not what you
have to play you you can also play Queen
captures and E5 it's such a fun position
point is that if Queen captures on A6
there's Bishop to D4 and how exactly are
you stopping Checkmate uh you have to
play something like Knight to E8 but I
mean it's not another great position
then uh the the pawn starts marching
forward you the Knight no longer defends
the bishop and you just uh fall apart
and of course if F6 then just broke
captures and G7 with check and that's it
captures captures with checking to G8
and this will be Checkmate so uh it's
possible but instead Magnus went for
this bishop to F1 idea uh obviously he
he he he does it for the memes uh Queen
captures on E2 by alireza and now Queen
captures an E5 and believe it or not it
was in this position on move 29 that
alireza firuzio resigned in the game as
uh he is very low on time and also it
doesn't appear that there is much that
he can do he had like a minute and a
half on the clock I can even check I
don't want to trick you guys uh let me
just quickly check how much all it is I
had yeah alireza resigned with two
minutes on the clock Magnus had some
five minutes but uh he knew that it was
just going to be slow torture there is
not much the
be done here basically uh the only move
you you have is Queen captures on D5 if
you don't have played this you're just
lost the Knight is saying if you move
the Knight the bishop is hanging uh if
you if you I mean uh there's just
nothing you have to play Queen captures
on D5 then everything gets traded off
and it's still a a terrible terrible
position there's uh just too much
happening for example if you play uh
after Bishop to D5 if you play something
like let's say Rook to D7 the Knight is
hanging the bishop is hanging and
there's not all that much to be done
here you cannot defend the Knight the B6
square is covered by the bishop so you
would you you basically resign here
there's no way to do it and if you don't
trade an E5 then you you don't have a
move it's I mean even even Queen t7 will
be deadly putting pressure on F7 putting
pressure on the Knight so alireza too
much to calculate two too little time on
the clock and he he congratulates Magnus
on winning This brilliant game so yeah
uh brilliant classical game by both of
them like I said first Mac Islands was
winning then alireza was winning or
maybe probably you know just close to
winning uh it's it's hard to save if
there's like a super engine defense or
something but uh yeah I if you played it
he probably would have won but then in
Armageddon Magnus wins his sixth
Armageddon in a row so Magnus did not
win a single classical game he just wins
all the armageddons after losing that
game to Fabi In classical in round one
uh so we'll see uh fun stuff happening
uh we're not going to discuss the
standings or anything we're going to
discuss it after I make a few more a few
more videos from this round uh but yeah
I think things are definitely happening
too bad for alireza but uh you know
Magnus definitely nibbling uh at those
points not not able to grab the full
three points uh always um grabbing uh
you know those Armageddon points uh so
yeah that's the game so or the game or
rather those were the games hope you
guys enjoyed a bit of a longer video but
we enjoyed the nice classical and the
nice Armageddon game so hope it wasn't
too much for you I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube and Mikhail
Sakari is and Brandon fukuda and Ricky
Johnson for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day